at the risk Pat of embroiling myself in
a major scandal it appears as though I
have appeared in an ad pushing
pseudoscience natural breast
augmentation this is just very very
strange okay viewer and Twitter user
Melissa Cobb yellow notified me that I
was in an ad for natural breast
augmentation all those also known as
bogus pseudoscience it's for a company
called sticky bra now I'm going to play
the ad for you to be clear I was not
asked to appear I did not agree to
appear the product that is being sold is
not one that I endorse or am even
familiar with let's take a listen to
this ad it is stunning
ladies and pull with substantive breast
tissue I got a quick question for you
do we really need bras apparently a bra
is not necessary according to a new
study women might be better off without
bras contrary to popular belief wearing
a bra can make breasts saggy err young
research claims women's breasts may get
saggy ER when they wear bras well the
tip is is to take off your bra so I've
reached out to the company Pat and I
indicated that I have been included in a
an advertisement for a product which I
am not only not familiar with I do not
endorse I was not asked if my light knit
likeness could be included here we have
not heard back from them yet the hell
was going on are they really able to do
this though because I mean though is a
compilation of media reports yeah do we
know if they actually did anything wrong
by doing this so I talked to a lawyer
friend of mine about this who said that
the clips so if you're on another news
show you can use our clip to do an
analysis and it presumably is sort of
what we would call fair use now fair use
is something you have to argue in court
if there's a challenge to it but I would
never challenge someone from doing that
because they're doing a news report this
is someone trying to sell a product and
my inclusion in that sales video because
that what's after all of these little
compilation clips is then saying by the
sticky bra right or whatever the case
may be that is using my light
yes in a in a dishonest way by the way
to make it appear as though I support
the the end result which is oh you
should buy this product and clearly I
have not said you should buy this
product well I am willing to do some
investigative reporting on lays
objective you need me to yeah Pat is
going to be up I don't know what that
means exactly but Pat is going to
investigate breast augmentation so now
Pat I've been misidentified as a
neo-nazi a dead gay teen who committed
suicide a harasser of women during the
entire gamergate situation and most
recently an apparent advocate of
so-called natural breast augmentation
which as far as my knowledge goes
doesn't really actually exist and I've
gotten flack for my scandals I'm
surprised that the show is still going
on after all that I hope that this
doesn't take the show down I really do
because I got a bunch of people after
the fact on Facebook who came across the
ad Melissa Coviello was the first one
and people were like David you know I'm
confused about your advertiser choice it
wasn't clear whether sticky bra was an
advertiser on the show or whether I was
endorsing it now why I would be involved
in endorsing breast enhancement products
yeah we're do not go to for that I'm not
I'm not the first person I would think
of to do that but in any case it's bad
out there folks it is real bad and I
encourage you if you want to write to
sticky bra or something I don't know I'm
hoping we can roll this into something
even funnier I don't know what that
would be necessarily but anyway that's
what's going on with stinky bra no I am
not endorsing sticky bra if you've gone
out and bought sticky bra whatever it is
as a result of my apparent endorsement
return the thing because I don't do not
stand by it